in support of this declaration we
mutually pledge to each other Our Lives
our Fortunes and our sacred honor that
comes down to the individual men in the
room right they themselves in particular
their names on the bottom of the
document right that's the particular
ending why is the beginning so universal
why is this is here when in the course
that means any time in history of human
events when in the course of you and mr.
because that's a 41 people that means
any people not not these people in the
room not the American people not any
people in particular any people who ever
lived in principle how are entitled it
says to a separate and equal station
under the laws of nature and of nature's
God it begins very universally and
that's handsome and pretty but if you
think about the structure of the
decoration those principles command
these things and that means these
principles are important they're
describing a way of living and if the
principles are true government needs to
be organized this away in the way that
is said by the Constitution that's the
argument
I